[Music]
[Music]
back at it again it's the fighter
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
I'm gonna start this by saying this
everything's a language learn the
language learn language if somebody
comes at you with Judo speak a different
language fight the grips and come at
them with wrestling you understand mix
it up somebody comes at you with [ __ ]
[ __ ] little Jiu-Jitsu little shits
little boxing speak a different language
if you're gonna box me I'm gonna be
kicking I'm gonna Dutch kick your
[ __ ] low legs keep my hands you're
playing the the stupid flute I'm hitting
you with that bass that's all it is
that's it and when I go low I go say say
it when I go high I go oi all right so
if I'm gonna hit you in the head the
last thing you hear is hey the last
thing you hear from me I'm a 90s space
yeah it's good when I chop your leg I go
say
Jay
I remember when when [ __ ] uh what's
that guy who fought Nate Marquardt he
was he was kicking Nate's legs one of
Nate's last fights in UFC um he he was
out of Dan Henderson's Camp uh french
guy uh annoyed uh
David wazzo Patrick
is such a stud look at him [ __ ]
that's my guy I love that Denver's
finest uh hold on I'm gonna find it he's
been [ __ ] oh Tariq salvading Curtis
Tark safety Savage dude he was getting
he was coming up and going boom and I
was like oh my God he was he was uh he
was the Kevin Garnett of MMA but French
I remember I remember realizing how
great uh Frankie Edward was when he was
uh when when he fought Aldo I was there
and I knew Aldo was going to try to kick
him with those leg kicks and the first
thing Frankie did the minute Aldo trying
to kick those legs he just would dive
into a double just die get him yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] these shorts you know
we got Frankie flying out from Jersey
that's where not next week because I'm
the First Lutheran Province the Fong
week maybe we get them on t5k who knows
we could double Dibble of firing a kid
it's Frankie Acker he's a legend I mean
come on he's out here might as well use
them a little fighting the kids love to
talk to the legend love to talk to the
legend
Frankie's the best and I've said this
before first food truck I ever did was
with him some New Jersey pizza yep yep
who's this
uh John Wayne Park oh wow where is he
training people he's an Australia dude
if he was here I would be friends Jazzy
she's a killer too that's his daughter
yeah remember John Wayne
when we toured you don't know John Wayne
par huh I know we had him on the podcast
since she was [ __ ] this [ __ ] now
John Wayne Park I remember remember we
were on Rogan with him yeah and he came
to like when me and Chin toward
Australia he came down then just showed
up to the show the best was John Wayne
par is a fighter so he's got deep lines
in his face and this is no diss on him
because he's awesome he looks great but
he's just he's just
how hard was that laughing yeah he's
lived there his daughter's a dime piece
by the way yeah um
I can't tell I can go to her she's
gorgeous and she's a fighter and she's a
[ __ ] Muay Thai Fighter wow is there a
video chin yeah hold on but so we're on
Rogan and [ __ ] shop and and John
Wayne who's just lived this man's life
he's all man is the death of a great
white shark he's got deep lines he looks
like he's a salty semen you know those
guys out to see whether it's been in the
sun their whole life his face just
weathered like leather weather weather
like their nose is all scarred yes
they've been through some [ __ ] just a
fighter a fighter and also just an
all-man moisturizer won't kill him but
shop goes like this shot Brandon goes
how old are you and John Wayne pargos
38.
and he looked so much older than me and
and Brennan just without missing a beat
Brandon goes you look young man
look at my bride and I do this I do a
slow right in front of him I just do a
slow yeah I go
do I could not we gotta find that on
Rogue in this I'm sure you can find that
it was such a way
man 70 yeah old school I mean it was the
only companion John Wayne par was on
right dude those clips will pop up of uh
those companions there's we have to
think wild but we also wild like sand
[ __ ] I mean no one was I mean we're
definitely one of the first guys look at
that body dude look at that body not bad
exactly it was impressive too because
we're giving you [ __ ] remember and then
you're like what do you want me to do he
took off the your [ __ ] shirt and then
you just shredded we were all like me
and Rob were both like that's a good
body yeah I'll take it and found it
because it was talking about barbarina
right oh yeah it's a terrible body yeah
yeah which I do but
oh yeah that was when I that was when I
was [ __ ] joking about what I do to
somebody and and Rogan took me seriously
remember when I said I'll show up at
your house and kill you and I was going
through a bit and he stopped my he
stopped it and he goes That's toxic
those people you're toxic was this on
the not the last one no it was a long
time ago when I said You shall you say I
was trying to do something I was
bringing it back to you I was saying
this I go look at that gay oh my God
yeah yeah yeah that's right I wore it on
purpose so Rogan the Studio's in
Woodland Hills which was a mile from my
house Rogan lived in Belton so we're all
in the same area and do these we just
there'd be a group text hey companion
day of yep let's do it we'd all just
rush over there yep those were the best
times of my life man but do you remember
that when I said you say something I'll
show up to your [ __ ] house and I was
about saying I'll [ __ ] you up remember
but Joe didn't get it so Joe goes you
know what dude you say that stuff that's
toxic the people around you I'm like hey
hey dude what the [ __ ] I was I was in
the middle of a bit and you're taking me
seriously some times Rogue now they play
it and they're like they straighten up
Tough Guy Brian Kelly hey fuckos
I was a hit I got stopped well because
some some could Rogan's one of the
comics he'll be in a silly mood you know
Brogan yeah but something most the time
yeah he's seriously we are like you and
I are silly right me and Theo are super
silly you and Chris are over the top
silly but it's a language and then
sometimes Brogan's the first comic where
because I thought I'd have to be because
you know a relationship between you and
Chris it's so silly so funny yeah you
guys doing bits but nobody's listening
It's the funniest thing in the world and
you're doing for each other
and I because you know you brought me
into comedy and so when I that was the
only in interaction I would see I'm like
oh that's how you have to act with these
guys it's not my I'll get silly
especially if I know you with you but if
I don't know you I'm a little more
reserved I'll just talk to you sure but
I thought it was like that way and then
I remember I Came In The Comedy Store
and you guys were doing your thing and I
was jumping into it everyone was like
can't come here he's like you're like me
man he said you don't have to do that
he's like don't you don't have to
entertain that [ __ ] that stupid
silly [ __ ] all the time he's like that's
not you I'm like really he's like no
yeah you're like me I was like oh yeah
but I'm I'm like I'm not opportunity
with it I'm like not good at that I'm
like between Rogue and Brian you know
I'm like in the middle I like to eat
silly sometimes yeah you like you like
to lie oh dude yeah Joe's not
comfortable in that so he gets a little
off kilter yeah you know so that's
really what it is where's my but
sometimes but sometimes you'll be doing
a bit and I know it's because we we
speak the same language yeah over 10
years now yeah all know it's a bit I'll
entertain it I was about to come at you
I was about to go and you show up my
house I know it was and I'll [ __ ] you up
serious clip and I I didn't realize that
you like because again the way you get
cut off I just saw the clip and it said
I I saw that that people were taking it
seriously
it sounds like I was being I was really
saying I'll show you how house and kill
you or something and Joe took it
seriously I'm like bro hey but I
remember like I was like oh he didn't
get the bit and we're moving on but
those things live on forever and there's
also no context in the clip too to like
what was the moments before this like
what was the but also yeah I was gonna
turn it on I kept trying to go back to
the bit but then I was like even on the
last Campaign which we finally got
together in Austin and then you when
you're doing you're like I'm not very
good at promoting you kept plugging
yourself that was a bit of a bit yeah I
know this so I can joke on it yeah
everyone was like shut the [ __ ] up
another [ __ ] Channel I'm like oh Joe
it's but you know what's great about it
you know what's great about that he did
pick up those tow holes yeah I'm just
saying though but you know what I'm
saying like that's like yeah I know
that's the running that's the bit yes
you know yeah that's the bit yeah
hey B let's take a little break because
Black Friday is coming up in Cyber
Monday and people are crunk for it where
do I get the best supplements on planet
Earth that's my question bro how do I
get nootropics for my brain sure talk to
me how about you get the lowest prices
on the best supplements on the planet
and get uh dude 60 off
Fitness all things nutrition all things
apparel pick up some of your friends
favorites then when I say friends I mean
me and Brian put your Alpha Brain or the
total human optimization the lowest
prices of the Year get you the jump
start on the New Year's right now the
sale ends December 4th so hurry while
supplies last go to onnit.com
f-a-t-k 60 off you Savages yeah usually
Alpha Brain that we push on there 10 off
December 4th sale ends December 4th so
hurry 60 off Friday just got a lot
better for you it's Black Friday on its
style through December 4th get you some
six percent off on it.com slash F our
longest sponsor our longest sponsor
shout out to on it this is Rain r e i g
n is talking about rain body fuel this
is tropical storm with BCAA bro that's
the new tropical storm daddy what's
going on here what's this about it
tastes like you're on vacation it gives
you energy really gives you energy tough
for you to open huh yeah not for the
faint of heart this stuff no a lot of
caffeine a lot of caffeine they got 300
milligrams of caffeine [ __ ] taste
consultation dude B vitamins up with the
Wazoo B3 B6 B12 electrolytes that's very
tasty Isn't it nice yeah it really is
seriously you want to feed you right it
tastes like it's um
there's no sugar in it zero grams of
sugar yeah how do they do sugar-free oh
that's cool brain sugar-free dude
technology is nuts
this is actually I can't believe that's
that's sugar-free dude it's Islander
sweat gives you energy
so Mark branched chain amino acids you
take those before or after a workout
um you could do either but you know I'm
probably gonna take them
uh that is so good after the fact
super nasty that's a coldie too that's a
cold one daddy damn it's like that's
crazy that has no sugar in it though and
that's all it's all sugar-free and then
also I'll be at the rain booth for the
Olympia doing all sorts of stuff there
probably it doesn't have that much
caffeine actually 300 milligrams yeah
it's not a cup of coffee cup of coffee
Brandon
a few cups of coffee who knew zero sugar
per can cup and a half total body fuel
but you love that new uh electrolytes
it's got uh branched chain amino acids
and it's so good uh I have to say and
it's got coenzyme C or Q10 Q10
electrolytes it's very tasty underneath
that yeah it's the flavor alert tropical
storm gets some rain
damn
yeah that's right well fun let's do
another uh fight campaign I just talked
to him oh yeah all right let's do it
wait for the Australia card that Big
Australia card what day is that let's
find out uh what date are you on the
road
when I need to be I think it might be
the 11th right or 12th
because there's one early February which
we're not doing February 11. that card
stacked that's done I'm all over that I
can't wait
those are so fun well you know what my
thing is that we're all a little older
aren't we yes we are no more mature we
have our 10 000 hours under our belt I
got I'll go back sometimes there'll be a
clip you know I don't watch my oh [ __ ] I
can't stand myself but I'll watch the
whole Clips I see it oh my god oh wow
it's something the [ __ ] I said I'm a
wild boy oh yeah you rock because you
like that you disagree and you like I
love to argue yeah and you go back to
that that card I want to argue and then
also I like to get silly but then
especially back then I wasn't known as a
comic so Megan's silly people would take
Serious yep remember when you and I
would always go I'm rich as [ __ ] yeah in
hindsight we were not rich as [ __ ] no
but it was funny to say because we're
having success some people are like [ __ ]
that yeah yeah it's like oh you think
we're serious it's all context yes as a
comic you can get taken out of complete
contacts yeah now Islamic Chef Alexander
Brooklyn I'm gonna go through it real
quick uh Islam micro Chef Alexander
Volcan office great fight tougher fight
for matcha than uh Charles Islam Market
Jeff Alexander volkanovsky when is
volcanovsky tap
let's just continue disrespecting no I'm
not I mean obviously
keep going on a piece of [ __ ] no that's
why I can't help it wasn't the show
that's why I can't have a moment I love
Alexander's respect no I'm not I love it
I've spent one one day with Alexander
volkanasi you would be jacked up rugby
balls I love him no I'm gonna say this
about volkanovsky if if Market Jeff is
not in the 55 pound division
he's he's right there he's a nightmare
for anybody else volkanovski Poirier
volkanovski would be sick I was just
gonna say that it would be slightly be a
handful for him oh my God but but
vulcanowski can strike like a
[ __ ] and he comes in there with
no problem Oh a nightmare you gotta
realize his mentality to win fights too
he's a hell of an act athlete speaking
of poor eight uh I was talking with Theo
this morning we were talking about stuff
still how much I missed him and he was
like I was like what are you doing man
he's like I was in Lafayette giving out
turkeys to people man with uh doesn't
pour it people don't realize how much
poor he gives back to this community
yeah so the funeral feels all crazy and
I I go uh you giving out turkeys bro
you're giving these people that need
[ __ ] food give them that dry ass bird
bro you give him this dry [ __ ] meat
that's the way you give back I said
you're not gonna toss a little grave in
there wet the whistle and he goes hell
he was ready to go there he goes hell no
man I give him that dry burn a handful
full of pepper
and with Mike Brown his coach was his
coach and after he won which I thought
was just it was a great fight and he
looked so [ __ ] good and and so uh I
say to [ __ ] uh I'm gonna find this
for you now
um and and we had a whole thing right
so yeah Islam while you're looking for
them so the podcast isn't coming to a
screech and halt uh yeah much of
volkanovsky yeah Rodriguez Joshua shout
out to Josh Emmett for getting the shot
that wouldn't have happened unless
Alexander jumped up you got Robert
Whittaker Apollo Costa fantastic fight
that's right that fight might be a
little oh yeah Robert Whitaker that
fight might be in a little bit of a
Jeopardy because Holocaust is now
demanding more money to take the fight
and he's been talking about how he can't
wait to get out of the UFC and fight
Jake Paul which is there's some smoke
there
um Parker Porter Peter Parker Porter uh
Justin tafa Tyson Pedro my favorites
Jimmy crew Alonzo benfield's a great
fight
it's a it's a stat card yeah right of
course you don't attack them right no
it's just funny here it is I go and what
time is what time is that fight at Jen
does it say I'll find out Australia is
like seven days ahead of us so if it's
uh the 12th here
oh it's still seven o'clock so still
prime time so they're fighting during
the day back in Australia
back in the day well I said this is this
is Dustin so I go unbelievable congrats
Dustin you're you're amazing but I sent
it to his coaches and everything and so
Thiago goes what a war and I go
beautiful and then uh Dustin goes thank
you and then uh and then a week later
Mike Brown goes amazing and then uh
Thiago was good timing Mike and and Mike
was late to the party and I go uh never
too late uh miss you fellas and then
Dustin goes Dustin goes hopefully I see
you soon man I go yes sir and then I go
I don't like the way you uh worked my
body last time I may have to bring my
feet into the mix the next time we quote
unquote move around I'm just saying stay
out of this Mike Thiago okay and then
Dustin goes he goes next time we move
around I'll make you leave your feet
huh that's a great saying I want to say
that I'll make you leave your feet
[ __ ] you know what they're gonna
do for him because he doesn't want to
fight our poor boy uh Darius the money
the money fight he doesn't want to fight
Darius no well Darius has Jesus on his
side number one he has all I mean if
anybody's going to heaven Tim Tebow
first he's right behind Timmy yeah and
and when somebody when somebody believes
they have holy ghost power uh
let's think they have holy ghost power
and he's the greatest of all time Jon
Jones oh is that true or it's like you
you think you think you're getting in
well yeah
he's got Philippians he's got
Philippians right here yeah you think
because you get one tattoo again yeah
Union it right you ain't getting it I
have a better chance my chances aren't
good he's a Jesus guy yeah
I would say Jon Jones has Jesus and the
devil on him you know depending and you
know so oh what I'm what I'm hearing is
UFC 285 Jon Jones is the most guaranteed
to fight the UFC doesn't care anymore
about Stipe they want Francis if he
isn't ready they don't they're like
right we're it's either gonna be Curtis
blades or Cheryl gone at this point
they're like John has to come back okay
so two UFC 285 March 5th hot second for
John to fight hot second uh March 5th
they're saying it's it's going down
whether he's fighting for a title he's
fighting one of the top dogs in the
heavyweight division it's good no
warm-up fight we're just throwing you
it's Jon Jones it's John you want to be
the greatest there's no warrants in the
UFC he's just gone ain't no warm-ups
because Blade's no punk now either no
curse blades is no his wrestling is
crazy he's striking now but now Chris
Blade's you know he's Juco wrestler I
don't know if he's now his champ I think
he's so much John no he was he was Juco
national champ oh yeah and Chael told a
story where John was at some uh
tournament and like the Iowa coach at
Oklahoma State coach was like holy sh
that that may be the best wrestler I've
ever seen would you say Ryan Bader was a
good wrestler
yeah yeah quality two-time All-American
oh you cradle much baby cradle okay
nobody cradles Ryan Bader train for that
fight
well no let me keep going let me just
keep going Daniel Cormier is David
McCormick hard to take down
I'd say so yeah was he a two-time
Olympian not one time but a two-time
Olympian huh so he knows a couple things
about wrestling he's pretty good at
Oklahoma State and and and when you're
that tall and doing a blast double
grabbing him and double legs every time
you've seen on DC's face he's like oh
[ __ ] when he got teamed down Against the
Cage yeah he got taken down so uh yeah
I'd say he can wrestle he can wrestle
okay that card's fantastic that to me so
fun if we do it who would you like to
see Jon Jones fight uh you anybody at
this point mark Harley I don't give a
[ __ ] I just want him back in there but
do you want to see him Punk do you want
to get him against Gano or Cyril gone or
I think got all things get messy if they
do get the deal done I think it's gonna
happen by March I'd like to see him
facing Gano for the belt an ideal
situation I think that's asking for too
much yeah I bet it's so gone
which to me it's his toughest matchup
100 yeah I think stylist good stuff's
match up now I think he beats everything
for John I think John beats everything
you do hey I
you're strong I've seen a Molly [ __ ]
heavyweight you're still on the job what
what what
did you get Molly [ __ ] oh yeah yeah I got
Ragdoll um
no you didn't I did not Ragdoll you
because nobody ragdolls you I don't do
it you didn't ragdolls not stronger than
you are not strong but dude it was not
fun didn't win the round no nothing and
now he was in there for five rounds
straight and I won't even name the
heavyweights but people we all know here
some world champion some the best ever
do it had their hands full had more than
their hands you lose around some
spillage and the time he was cutting
weight barely training I was in the best
shape of my life okay and and there's
levels of this game did you guys wrestle
strike uh striking light striking have a
full go grappling wrestling five minute
round and how do you feel he stayed five
five minute rounds okay that's a
disaster beat the [ __ ] out of everybody
any these beat the [ __ ] out of the
heavyweights [ __ ] and I remember
thinking back then I'm like God would
this be a nightmare never coming there
yeah and what was he weighing then 230
in the off season uh then he was getting
ready for five two fifteen two thirties
no problem for him to walk around that
no no no 2 15. Savage
the research of fun [ __ ] fight
companion though because that card is
stacked I remember I was backstage with
you when I saw
um Gustafson after the fight after the
fight with Jon Jones I felt like crying
well dude I've never seen uh I couldn't
look him in the eye like his whole side
of the space that's purple and so his
job well I I I saw him standing and he
was like just he kind of looked over and
I looked at him and then I looked away
because I didn't want to see him in that
how big was he he's massive this is so
big way bigger than me way so big so big
every bit of six five oh I would say
maybe six six I don't know he looks
Justin's the best to ever do it if he
was born at a different time stud he's
doing right now a prime Gusman
beats yawn beats everybody monster it
just so happened in his prime your two
gentlemen named DC and Jon Jones and
that's the way it goes well the the
Anthony uh Ronald Johnson
God Rest his soul uh when they bumped
heads that's kind of that [ __ ] him
yeah that was such a bummer look at him
though heavyweight now
he should be that is a big big man and a
rough dude
huge
yeah
you looking forward to uh Thanksgiving
buddy a little time I like Thanksgiving
do you yeah I always like Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving uh
third on my list for holidays I'm going
to Grandma's house Chris are you going
oh you're not having at your house no
lazy yeah I know lazy I know also so
much easier I mean somebody's house do
their thing your parents are in New York
my sisters haven't a thing your parents
don't want to fly no my dad's like get
the [ __ ] out here but my dad flew he's
flying in Salt Lake City not in New York
yeah they're going to New York
getting my dad to move
he likes his golf he likes his iPad he
listens to Old Radio old radio I love
already myself I prefer when I listen to
when I land every Sunday I turn on am
and listen to football games I love old
radio I love old radio and then he
listens to a different podcasts listen
to podcasts
he doesn't listen to this you know he
don't listen to this religiously and
golden hour is my mom
no your mom listens to this oh big time
I love your mom non-stop shout out to
your awesome patreon subscriber oh no oh
yeah that's awesome we have to pay for
it whatever my ex used to listen to
veteran kid all the time really Amanda
all the time should we get offended no
you're gonna stop listening she was like
you guys are so funny but then we said
some [ __ ] oh my girl stop yeah she's
never listened to it she's like oh this
you guys are atrocious yeah well her
family was listening to it and it was
kind of they were like wait a minute oh
we got in trouble over the years if
you're doing it right you're gonna
offend a good amount of your family a
good amount of your family Daddy drank a
lot of wine last night I don't give a
[ __ ] oh you're back drinking around
Thanksgiving I'll drink yeah my diet's
off around because not only the
Thanksgiving was bossy's birthday on
Saturday so it's like I'm not gonna give
me a diet during then you know yeah so
yesterday I had to get smog check for my
[ __ ] car and he took me 20 minutes
look down the street I saw Chick-fil-A I
went Daddy's hungry yeah you ever had a
Chick-fil-A breakfast sandwich
outstanding my God and she goes
outstanding is you on uh the Chick-fil-A
sauce or would you like some jelly on
their way ah jelly sounds nice jelly she
goes you want uh grape or uh strawberry
I'm not yes great yeah oh man it was
nice yeah I sat there here's the thing
because we cross the street from high
school kids are in there it's packed and
the kids are in there they they're
watching Netflix movies dude they're
just all sitting around eating and
watching someone puts up their big
[ __ ] they're just watching movies I'm
like yeah
[ __ ] did I ever tell you when Rogan and
I went
on the glacial Lake in Alaska and we
went looking for a sicka black tail I
think it's sicka or sipa sikka Blacktail
a deer didn't see a [ __ ] thing right
not a thing because even the deer were
like oh it's too rainy and shitty up
here we're going way down but that's
okay and um we're eating we're eating
dried uh yeah Sitka black tail we're
eating dried Mountain food you know
dehydrated food and pouches put water
what soldiers do cool all I want is to
kill him a deer so I can eat his heart
some [ __ ] meat overall first dude and
uh we're both like whatever but we're
having see that that's um that's me
making broken laugh the whole [ __ ]
time like that's all I had he was my
best audience and I'm just [ __ ] with
him the whole time and that was good but
then they draw the seaplane came because
the weather front was moving in so we
had to cut it short because the sea
plant was coming in and they brought us
McDonald's they brought us Egg McMuffins
the best thing I've ever had it's it was
the best thing yeah we've ever had ever
of all time and they were cold and it
was the best thing of all time if you
haven't had that [ __ ] and you've been
eating shitty food oh it's fantastic you
know you don't want to eat it all the
time and Daddy got gray Daddy got gray
you guys were young there well not that
much you went through some Chevy I did
Buddy it aged both of us it aged both
I'll admit that we've both aged about
solid thing it put us in overdrive and
some dark hair and I was cute Brogan was
young back then too man look at you guys
similar faces
similar could be brothers Rogan's young
there man
ah I gotta call him dude I was watching
uh
I was watching uh Bill Burr and Bill
Maher podcasting Bill Burrs podcast
Monday morning
Thursday afternoon podcast yeah so he's
been having big guests on there uh which
reminds me of uh Tom and Bert but he's
been having a big guests on there he had
Bill Maher on there you can tell they're
not like great friends you know Bill you
never try to Bill Bill Burt
[Music]
I love both of them Bill Burr's my
favorite of all time he's the only comic
I'm actually scared of yeah this is who
he is and what he represents he scares
me so good
so yeah he was on the he was doing his
policy at Bill Maher on you can tell
they don't know each other but they've
both been doing comedy around the same
time long time 30 years something years
they're talking about their calm and
stuff like that and then uh you know
bill has his black belt in politics Bill
Maher does she starts talking about
politics and then bill goes I'll tell
you one thing and he goes you know like
how [ __ ] up was it it was like in 2012
or 2009 the housing market went crashed
right and bill was like how the [ __ ] is
this my roof had water damage and
basically he he had to repair it and
then uh the insurance came and he had to
pay off the insurance so he's going
through this whole thing and Bill Maher
goes listen because you know he has
black belt in politics Bill margos I'm
not going to talk to you at the end of
the bar about politics he's like it
sucks for your roof this is a bigger
politics are bigger than that for you
that's your masaki is like that's
horrible this what we're talking I
forget what topic they're talking is
it's bigger than this he's like you're
one individual case and you're based in
your politics based off your individual
experience he's like this one don't
discuss politics with the guy at the end
of the bar he said because for his
perspective he's gonna have one
perspective but politics don't work like
that it's the masses yeah so he's trying
to describe the bill they get into it
Bill Maher is trying to describe it to
Bill Burr yeah so they kind of get into
it yeah you know both neither one's a
punk especially Bill Burr smash you Bill
if you ever seen him and Theo he was
perfectly that day he was getting silly
and he was not having it yeah my God he
was not happy yeah he scares me I've
done podcasts with Bill I've done live
podcast and if he's not having he's not
having it we had a great time you ever
see him when he did uh
kill Tony no and they they just asked
him to do it and he you know killed Tony
great platform blown up shout out to
Tony his Cliff love the show Dave Luke's
on there all the time it's my future
Bill didn't always sign up for sits down
and the comment goes up and they're
making fun of him and Bill was what is
this what is this what is this you give
the guy one minute who the [ __ ] one
man you're [ __ ] his kids this ain't
comedy what the [ __ ] just
but he was like standing it was cool
actually because he was like trying to
give that comic the benefit of the doubt
like because he he's just contrarian
it's like if everyone's making fun of
the person he's like you know what
you're [ __ ] wrong here's the reason
you shouldn't make fun of him but his
points are great he's brailling that too
we're like oh [ __ ] so he wasn't having
because he felt like he felt bad for
those Comics get up there yeah same
thing happened with me at The Comedy
Store I wore this you know I wear weird
[ __ ] I wear that jumper we're all in the
shows Bill Rogan Diaz
you Delia Theo is crazy sure I remember
where that jumper it was a blue jumper
yeah I remember that I walked in
rhoden's lighting up everyone's like me
I'm like oh [ __ ] Romans like just
wait till Bill comes in like oh you know
because like he's my favorite I'm like
oh no so my head I'm like [ __ ] Here
Comes Bill Burr dude and I'm like and
the whole time like maybe it's just walk
out front so he didn't see me blah blah
I'm sitting back there I think you and I
were talking Bill walks out I'm like oh
[ __ ] and Romeo's bill look at [ __ ] look
at what the [ __ ] Shop's wearing and I'm
like here we go and Bill goes what what
about it because look he's in that
[ __ ] gay jump or whatever the [ __ ]
you just mad cause you can't wear it you
had a body like yo I'd [ __ ] wear that
I'd wear that [ __ ] what are you
making fun of them for I'd wear that
[ __ ] thing I look like I'd wear that
[ __ ] thing then he goes I mean and
then I was like oh my God he's the gun
for me I was like I love it I love him
more right and then he goes I mean yeah
he looks like a janitor from a Broadway
musical but who gives a [ __ ]
still kills you out to go [ __ ] yeah it
feels great so I don't know if you
wanted to see this but this is like a
three minute highlight Club just because
I remember hearing their argumentation I
watched it this morning and but and then
bill was like what I love too you know
you and I have arguments or whoever if
you're doing probably have arguments and
people like oh they'll take sides or
whatever and then it's so serious in
their world what they don't realize is
how good a friend everybody is where and
Bill even goes you're not because they
argue and then you can tell it's like
awkward and Bill goes you're not one of
those guys that can't argue and they get
all sensitive right
Bill Marcus now and he goes we're still
going to hug it in the parking lot right
and Bill Margo's I'll probably suck you
off
good good yeah man that's important
voices I think what we're dealing with
is there are two camps in this world one
is the camp like all of us that believes
that America's good and we want to keep
our institutions and then there are
people that want it to tear they want to
tear it down those people they want if
they want to they want to discredit all
that that's where this idea of uh so
Tampax now sponsored Tampax sponsored
two trans men
yeah one of them has a dick I saw a band
on Tampa okay now you see why Balenciaga
did no so Balenciaga who's in Coots with
they were with uh Kanye they're with Kim
they work with both of them
they did a campaign right they fired
Kanye for his anti-semitic [ __ ] and then
they did all this horrible [ __ ] to him
and then
um they come out with a campaign
yesterday that's
kind of promoting child pornography so
it's kids and like I saw that like weird
like well there was a problem
and then they and then they go they
apologize they'll release one today and
shows this lady with a feet up on a desk
and then on the desk is literally child
pornography well no it's entrepreneur is
it or is it no there's somebody zoomed
in on a trip I thought it was I thought
it was actually the laws a concerning
job no no it shows kids naked watch it
yeah it's nuts what's the brand
Balenciaga Valencia they're screw dude
so so uh uh tambex was getting serious
blowback oh I saw I saw band Tampax and
now now it's been Balenciaga and Candace
Owens said the same thing she goes
balenciagas so you do this weird child
abuse thing uh are they gonna seize your
bank account like did they Kanye are you
gonna do you have to take the necessary
steps that Kanye did like how terrible
is this dude this dominatrist [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] were you guys thinking
yeah I don't know what are you thinking
so they're in bondage office holding
teddy bears dressed as bondage outfits
yeah I don't know what the [ __ ] they and
then they leave Twitter they're so
[ __ ] dumb
did you see uh it's insane they did it
even worse one that's that's not
innocent to me you [ __ ] those people
it's weird you didn't see that no no he
didn't see they're putting a [ __ ] you
know anybody how many boxes they have to
check before these things get cleared
yeah this went through several steps and
they know what the [ __ ] they're doing oh
they're pieces of [ __ ] man I'll never
wear it again it's terrible that's your
marketing get the [ __ ] out
that little innocent kid that's nuts
dude
I mean in Canada songs like Candace
Owens Made a great Point again there's
Bond there there's
I don't know I don't know can I read
what you're referring to but canason's
made a great Point she goes hey
Hollywood keep the same energy half
Blondie I got the same demand just for
Kyrie and Kanye
like you want to throw these people
under the bus and then when someone in
your in your network [ __ ] up we
apologize for just my unsettling
documents in our campaign the company
continues in this statement it takes
them out very seriously I'm taking legal
action against the parties responsible
for creating the set okay and including
unapproved items from our spring 23
campaign photo shoot so I'll tell you
what hold on we strongly condemn abuse
of children in any form we stand for
children safety so I think what happened
really I think what happened was that
the people they hired the the set
designers which is very legitimate the
set designer got into some mischief and
decided to do some [ __ ] don't put the no
be you're giving too much of an out they
everything happened
do these things I promise you they
didn't I promise you they didn't at the
level balance out your works I promise
you they did it well not a chance I
would say I would say sometimes this is
the problem no no this is the problem so
Kanye is anti-Semitism was he off you
know what I'm saying no no but they have
people like this who are who have so so
a company like this has an art
Department right and then they
subcontract out and that's what I'm
saying oh no it sounds like but
something was missing no no look at this
no there's not miss me I guarantee you
it's not missed you give them to you're
giving these pieces of [ __ ] too much
credit it's involved in yeah of course
it is and then look at the one they
posted earlier today can I show you so
what you're talking about because that
was confusing to me so I looked it up
um McQueen the tick tocker okay so
Gabriel uh shot the objects campaign as
part of toy stories to your project in
which you created colorful images of
children in their homes and twists sorry
the the part you're referring to is
um a a tick tocker
says the photos seemed crazy and when
she dug a little deeper in her video she
shares a screenshot of an image on the
Balenciaga website's homepage the image
is seemingly harmless picturing a small
handbag on top of a pile of papers you
zoom in on the papers and get words like
speech Coalition sexual intercourse
pornography and sex appear what she's
saying is those words and phrases are
coming from this uh case Ashcroft versus
Free Speech Coalition a court case
arguing that images that don't actually
depict child pornography but only imply
it should be legal so like seemingly
somebody snuck those in in a very
deliberate way
like a little Easter egg and blonde tag
is not they're not one just yeah just go
ahead this is good and they also
announced in 2019 they would no longer
be hiring models under the age of 18.
but I mean but then
fine but they're yeah they're they're
doing child models now oh should you
bring up the one the desk one two that
was posted this morning and they're
getting absolutely
I don't know where where they posted
bring up Balenciaga
um
child porno desk
uh mountain lion versus Bobcat right now
what do you mean well I think you're
suffering from a little case of mountain
lion uh no that's not it yeah that now
that's the that's the no no
there's another one because they had
another one that there that they were
going to post it's okay again and I
understand I like you and I like where
you're going with this I I appreciate
her outrage I promise I think it might
be a little bit off I promise you I'm
not all right I'm gonna show you right
now this girl's gonna take talk but it
was what I just described was
I think what you're referring to it's on
a desk the documents that are from a
court kids about Balenciaga desk ad
controversy
I think that's the one bubble no it's
not they did they released another one
people are like are you out of your
[ __ ] mind so not in handbag it's just
that yeah yeah
um let me just go images and see if this
pops up
I'm telling you I watched I looked at it
this morning is it possible no I promise
it's not nope just send it to me send it
to me me and Jay talked about this
morning
so
go backward I assume go back to me to
the news so I can read it I want to see
this because I'm I'm gonna have to throw
away all my Balenciaga stuff I mean okay
well yeah I don't even know what they
are click on the thing I just emailed
you
and I think hold on go back hold on so
uh this is Marx
this one she's at the scroll down
if you do who's that lady she's kind of
cute
this one nope here you go here you go
chin yep not making this up why would I
make that up oh there you go hold on
let's watch this clip over here and then
I'm sending the actual picture
stay tuned Valencia I've got to do an
update because I'm seeing a lot of
discourse everywhere
that by the way that one back there
still had a deeper meaning it was about
raising awareness of abuse it was social
commentary a lot of things anyways new
campaign up on Balenciaga that's the new
campaign B then look at the then they
zoom in on the pictures that shares her
feet on seeing this chick stick talk and
got like this comment as well this is
about the social commentary I just want
to come back to this article on
wallpaper and the quote that I shared in
my first Tick Tock where valenciaga is
quoted as saying it is an exploration of
what people looked and received as gifts
and there's children in there anyway um
campaign and they zoom in on it's naked
kids
sent me hold on there you go and see
they blur it out
so that book that she see the book right
there if you open that in that book that
Michael boram's yeah book is naked
children
it's more child pornography
can you look up who Michael Moore is it
is it is it he's an artist and he was
taking pictures of his own kids what is
it I don't know you know what I'm saying
are we looking into this too deeply here
no you should look into it deeply yeah
but if it's the artist I don't like to
give people out to be but if it's an
artist it's not there's no images on
there right in the book there's hater
and filmmaker
um look at that Valencia roses another
creepy fashion campaign featuring art
that glamorizes pedophilia and
cannibalism so says the article let's
see yeah see but but then again this is
not so what do you want to find article
that says
no no hold on but this is this is um
hold on we have to go back for a sec
because that guy's a legit artist right
look at it he's a legit artist and and
there are no kids there are no kids in
that ad though in the book she's on
though that's the thing it's a nod to
the other Campaign which field which
featured naked children do you think
there's something sneaky going on I
don't know yes yeah I don't know
I don't know I mean it's possible it's
just all a coincidence Jesus Christ it
could be no [ __ ] no no
pornography but what Brennan's saying to
get past this many you know
so many bodies so many lives at that
level I'm not gonna defend Balenciaga
I'm not gonna die in that Health Zone
uh you know I'm going to take your word
for it yeah but the guy is a Belgian
painter I don't mind if if they feature
a Belgian painter and an adult ad who
happens to be controversial if he
clamorizes I don't know if he Glam I
don't know the artist so
um yeah I don't know either so it says
be warned before you Google this book
the playlist book are very disturbing
and featuring toddlers running around
naked looking at and holding bloody
severed body parts many of the kids are
covered in blood there's also drawings
of children dressed in well cult-like
costumes wearing all black with hoods
covered in the face and their entire
head when the drones featured a circle
of children gathered around a large
rodent who is going to be sacrificed
other images include an adult wearing
the same black hooded outfit and holding
hands of a minor with the same outfit I
I I'm never going to censor an artist an
artist other work by this guy borums
features adult men walk around with
their heads and feces completely covered
yeah
[ __ ] exchanging uh bloody body parts and
eating that yeah he's obviously a dark
artist but do you think this I'm not
gonna censor that guy for the attention
yes but I I didn't really same thing
with Kanye like Kanye's done some crazy
[ __ ] yeah he did not realize going after
Jews what the repercussions can be same
with Balenciaga
now now are we going to require
Balenciaga to to educate himself on
child sex trafficking and take a course
and should we seize their bank accounts
like we did with Kanye
are we going to keep that same energy is
that the the course right protocol here
right
I'm just gonna do that to Kanye West
that's my problem
um I I think we're in dicey territory a
little bit I don't because I think
neither all of us are looking into every
little detail I worry that we we get
into some censorship uh with artists so
so that guy Michael Borman he may be I
mean he looks like an amazing artist who
does some crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] that guy but
even with naked that's your right [ __ ]
that's your right to say that I'm saying
doesn't mean he's not a [ __ ] like art
disturbs an artist like holy [ __ ] you
know it's all that right so it goes back
to the Robert Maple Thorpe thing like
should the National Endowment of the
Arts give him money first things because
he had a penis his finger stuffed in a
giant piece so it's the way that belongs
out yeah Chris Nixon urine there's a lot
of offensive stuff but I'm never gonna
tell an artist not to do that the
question is
it's the way they use it I would say
this I would say this you have a right
to be outraged and boycott Balenciaga
and if they want to take that chance
they can go ahead and take that chance
and they got you can do whatever you
want and I do things you're saying if
you're going to cancel Kanye for what
his stuff said was horrible yeah
I'll get that same energy same energy
you can't pick and choose Hollywood yeah
because Balenciaga provides outfits to
those Hollywood stars but we're seeing
him a free pass oh they messed up not a
big deal no hold on you you Kanye lost
billions of dollars yeah what about this
in this giant Corporation but there's a
there's a double standard with the left
and the right anyway always I mean both
sides have their issues but like um what
you remember that that very credibly
Biden had a very credible
uh sexual allegation of sexual assault
against them by Tara Reid very credible
and to the point where where the mother
called Larry King so and and that was
very conveniently forgotten by Kamala
Harris who said she believed the woman
but then she got a chance to be a
[ __ ] but these all these people who
speak for me too and women but somehow
the president United States because she
didn't keep that same energy so nobody
keeps the same energy when their guy is
there well it's all inconsistent how
about the left just now admitted to the
hunter Biden laptop you know this they
just now were like we admitted it when
they've denied denied denied and finally
now they're like yep there's that laptop
that that's not good they're
investigating it it's like yeah we
report on this two years do you think do
you think that uh Kanye in in what's
what happens to Connie in three years
he's fine 100 yeah he makes his way back
yeah he's gonna make his own he's gonna
make his own uh shoes he owns the rights
to the slides I know for a fact he's
already worked on his own production
company and China making his own shoes
where he's gonna full control of it his
fan base still rabid he'll be fine you
know so will Balenciaga this will be a
thing in a week we'll forget about this
it's interesting too do you see that
that shooter that shot the the gay club
in Colorado Springs yes
so this is so for the left right and
again I'm not playing anti-trans well
the anti-trans
mother uh white privilege all this [ __ ]
and then it comes out his pronouns are
they in them
I don't know
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah he was a magic guy
well he was just like he was upset and
shot them up baba but here's the thing
as a guy in the middle there's a guy in
the middle
not in the right I'm I'm in the middle
uh this guy SBF Samuel bankman uh fine
yeah what's his name right what about
him uh well he he was the founder of
FTX no I know that yeah he was Biden's
number two campaign donor he gave more
to that he gave to Republicans but he
gave them more you talked about this on
Monday I know but but I don't hear a lot
right now
well where's the energy that I'm going
to this guy's this guy you know did some
really bad [ __ ] and a lot of people lost
a lot of money where's that watch what
happens with the media with it because
this guy's not a Maga crazy far-right
conspiracy guy like the guy that broke
into Pelosi's house yeah those are gay
fight there's a double standard double
stand watch how they sweep that under
the rug you won't hear anything about
that Matthew I'm just asking I'm asking
for objective news from both Fox and CNN
I want objective news you're never gonna
get it if you're getting your news from
either one of those yeah out of your
[ __ ] mind if I got my problems with
Fox I got my problems with seeing
they're both out of their mind give me
objective [ __ ] news you guys want to
hear an inching angle about that
specifically is that which one uh the
FTX thing in regards to celebrity
endorsements because Kim Kardashian was
fined and other celebrities have been
fine because you have to disclose like I
always paid 250k to post a story about
this crypto specific cryptocurrency
when you just get people to go in this
commercial it's like Steph Curry's in a
commercial he's not saying you need to
go buy this thing but but do they have
any responsibility for endorsing
something on the other side of it when
it collapsed you saying they're supposed
to do their due diligence before they
endorse it like there's this grayer
where because Kim posted like hey you
guys should go invest in ethereum that's
directly in violation of uh you know the
uh the laws against but but is she aware
of what exactly you know she I would
highly doubt she should be aware of the
law but I'm saying she wasn't aware of
the exact kind of Ponzi scheme this
gentleman was doing this was another
cryptocurrency I'm like it in the past
that just it violates the rule that if
you're promoting a stock it'd be like
you're like hey I'm gonna give you some
money like say this is the best stock
ever you had to disclose that that's the
worst thing right so she multiple
celebrities got in trouble in the past
for doing that oh God that's a gray area
with with FTX because they got a bunch
of people to appearing like funny
commercials without directly saying like
you guys should invest in this thing
it's a little bit more iffy but people
are filed a class action lawsuit to be
like Steph Curry Tom Brady Like Larry
David Marshall you know what's crazy I
was listening this uh expert talked
about it and he was talking about he had
a hundred thousand dollars invest a
hundred thousand dollars
and so they were like so what do you
think is going to happen he's like do
not count on getting your money back you
say it's gone yeah there's no chance
you're getting money back because now
you can sue and do whatever you want
because the chances are you might just
take you on the chin we're not getting
our money back like holy [ __ ] if you
invest in ft's in crypto and certain
things you know I had some people come
to me and they really laid out they
really laid out some money
that they said this is
very careful remember how careful I was
I was like now hold on I'm not using
this platform to tell you to buy frog
because if I do that then that's on you
know if you so so we could we could have
gotten everybody together I don't touch
that stuff I'm saying but we could have
gotten everybody together if we got we
said say we had a bunch of friends who
are [ __ ] [ __ ] and we said guys
you got to buy these these nfts because
we're buying them we push it then you
then you push it then everybody buys a
dump then everybody does it then then
the price goes up then we sell our nft
it's so short-sided but that's also
called unethical and that's called
dishonest practice [ __ ] Behavior
were you Nancy Pelosi yeah you can't do
that and that happens all the time with
crypto and it happens all the time and
something so they came to me and they
said um and they gave me a really good
thing and they said you should teach
stand-up comedy
and I said I can do that the problem is
the problem is
I am not going to have a thousand
students who I'm teaching comedy to
around the world let's say if I really
had a marketing thing people would give
me a certain amount of money
because I don't know that you can teach
stand-up my my class on standup is
really simple it'd be this fast I'd be
like write every day write only what you
think is fine perform all the time keep
it in front of the mirror yep and I'll
see you in 10 years and that's it see
you in 10 years and that's it that's it
there's no secret there's no there's
nothing nothing to do I'm not gonna you
know nothing else that's it that's all I
can do I I don't have any techniques
which you stand up sometimes I care now
how other Comics right and stuff like
that I could teach I Could Teach an
improv Workshop like a teacher I've seen
study Workshop no politicians acting
you're the best 100 get for the job yeah
you know what I bet you could teach
though or I know I believe you could
teach the grammar of a joke what what
constitutes a probably but it wouldn't
mean anything to you until you did it
like I I never started now you wouldn't
understand you can identify it helps you
identify what's funny right now if I say
to him if I go a joke has a certain
economy of words emphasis you go yeah I
know because we're always in that case
yeah but when you first started you
would have been like but no I gotta just
get out and tell a story
I would try
it's too advanced
um like what what would you say is the
irreducible component of of a joke like
what's the one thing you gotta surprise
yourself first surprise yeah yeah you
gotta you gotta kind of like I know I've
written a great thing when I go [ __ ] I
just came up with a great I came out a
great thing on abortion yeah recently
and I went that's the [ __ ] essence of
the joke yeah that's it
because it surprised me yeah but even
with all that being said it'd be just
getting up get up non-stop yeah
I want to learn how to box I want to
learn how to fight be an MMA fighter
watch well even if it's just give me
some advice it was just I'm like do it
you got to do it do it there's only one
way to learn I'm doing it non-stop yeah
adjust the price of pain ten thousand
hours that's it with anything yeah I
said if I write a self-help book please
buy it because it's going to be one page
yeah it's going to say it takes forever
you're just gonna open up it says get up
it takes forever yeah yeah
I mean this is the pro my problem with
uh people who deconstruct the learning
process and give you 12 easy steps or
three easy steps I do believe I do
believe there are principles in teaching
so if I were teaching you wrestling I'd
say you'd say if you because you're
Foundation control the head and the hips
if you can control someone's head and
hips let's start with just know that or
or uh if I said do you have about boxing
it's not boxing yeah boxing is good
punching is good but it's where you're
punching from where are your feet it's a
foot game you can tell people where
where to focus
huh I'm not buying your boxes you're not
buying my boxing book hopefully Mike
Tyson would do that
yeah but again it's like you said but
even then he there's not well I can
teach you principles and then before if
you're punching me in the face at full
speed yeah in real time because I know
it's for you what yeah
you see Elon on Twitter posted he found
all this all this gear in Twitter
headquarters that said hashtag stay woke
he's posting just laughing he's like
throwing this trash
stay woke stay well really that's what
you're dealing with there man
thank you
those are the people that ran it man
it's hilarious
entire closet yeah what's the camera
you're working for
now how do you think they treated guys
like you and me be
why did I gain 200 000 followers when
Elon took over that's weird
oh that's normal
yeah Bots are interesting because what
um part of the uh so so when Elon said
that you know you have Bots a lot of
this is Bots well before you bought it
right use for marketing yeah yeah a lot
of marketing companies would you get
bots to push
traffic toward your particular product
in fact you can even you can start with
a product that's really controversial
and then replace it with something else
but then you have all those followers
well because yeah that's like the Bots
thing right because if if that thing's
trending it's getting a lot of comments
whether it's a robot a Russian or an
actual human being in America the more
that gets common the more it's going to
push it up and now look at how many up
to 42 percent of uh Conor McGregor's
followers are fake 38 uh silvas all
these yeah 40 of John Jones followers
fake that's amazing well that guy that
comment says what's the percentage for
other celebrities I know Kim Kardashian
on Instagram they did like a sweep of
bots and stuff she lost Millions sure I
don't think she's buying them I think
it's just a product of you know it's
just she's out she's social media a
magnet if she wears your product came on
yeah I remember when uh
I think it was Jessica Simpson when if
she wore a pair of your boots
like a a everybody was like where'd you
get those boots oh yeah their sales
would go through the [ __ ] roof that's
how Kanye is still I mean with
with certain brands like Dickies and
certain things you'd wear at once and
off the shelf now AG from toll called me
goes did you guys did you just drop the
the podcast and talk about to hold I go
yeah me and Brandon were talking about
tohold and tiger thick and he goes I can
tell by the traffic hitting the website
yeah like you you know three of our
influence not not a ton compared to like
a big Shake remover yeah if you came out
Cristiano Ronaldo he just passed he's
the first one ever I think he has 300
million followers or something he's the
first one ever 500 million like first
one ever to pass have you seen what it
cost you to pay for one image of Kim
Kardashian with your stuff on oh my God
how much so I think it's something like
just for one picture it's like
Cristiano's dude he's half a million
away from or half yeah he's the greatest
half a billion yeah he's almost at a
billion dude
what that's crazy that's not that's how
popular soccer is and that's how special
what that guy is yeah that's how special
that is also older like he's not his
problems he's just left Manchester too
Manchester yeah he's mad because he
didn't start in a couple games well and
the but they were also like losing he
wanted out of the contract he makes all
the money
37.
I look at him look at that body
freak
complete [ __ ] freak yeah he's uh he's
just he will win at all costs
it's crazy right
nuts
you see how high he jumps and that that
you're seeing when they turn out the
lights and doing Corner kit yeah it's
sick he can see he still makes it yes
like what no [ __ ] he can feel it
that's good that's a pretty good uh
considered around I'll say six two that
has wrote during the goalkeeper measure
by approximately 41 inches which is
insane it's insane the highest ever
reached in the NBA is 48 inches I
disagree with that well I guess because
the high thing the average bird will
jump the NBA players is 28 which is not
good
but I'm assuming that's like the seven
foot tall guys but there are some guys
that one guy jumps 53 inches
yeah Morant John Morant jumps so [ __ ]
high it's weird
it has to be interesting Jesus Christ
then do you see fauci's uh final press
conference
I did not
it's interesting because the end of it
this lady just goes real quick uh I want
to talk about the origins of the league
in the lab and the lady jumps in she
goes excuse me well enough we've had
enough uh you know you got to wait your
turn we're not having this you're not
going to disrespect me you're not going
to respect Dr Falcons last and and then
this African dude who's in there goes
hold on chill she doesn't legit question
we're all wondering if this is last
press conference does he have anything
to say about now we have more evidence
that the actual viruses leaked from a
lab that he's funded and he's been part
of
she should not be shunned we're all
thinking this she'll press conference
over like holy [ __ ] dude well that's the
whole thing unravels they know that's
the most dangerous thing he could
possibly answer honestly would be
addressing of the lab League they're
open up criminal investigational yeah
yeah he he wants no part of that
this lady takes no [ __ ] either kind of
sexy we have a process here I'm not
calling out which is the worst gig ever
and you're being you're being you're
being disrespectful to your colleagues
and you're being disrespectful to our
guests I will not call on you if you
yell and also you're taking time off the
clock because Dr fauci has to leave in a
couple of minutes I'm done I'm not going
back into four questions
um this guy sticks up
[Music]
is it disrespectful I'm done Simon I'm
done I'm Simon I'm done I'm done with
you right now
lame I like that she stood up for it
though [ __ ] I mean she has to do it I
like anybody who gives it back
like I may not do this
how have
you sure so close what they should do
that environment
asks right now
but but how about how about can we get
demonized for this I'm gonna [ __ ]
into it anyways but how about with the
vax with the boosters notice how it's
gone down where before was like get
vaccinated you won't get coveted now and
then was get vaccinated you most likely
won't you know you're not gonna be as
sick now it's get vaccinated you can
still get it but you're not gonna die so
they they're they keep pushing posters
one of the mainstream media Outlets
today just said this which I thought was
interesting
um and then fast because you should
still wear a mask you know you should
all be boosted if you're having
Thanksgiving [ __ ] you dude are you out
of your mind
ah damn I'm sorry there was the thing
about this and then what's the what's
the virus popping up with kids right now
they're worried about overrun hospitals
uh the r
what the is that Bella no it's the it's
two syllables
hold on let's go no sorry news
so it's the flu right now is popping of
course as it always is RSV
so RC is popping we do they're saying
and they won't admit this during that
because the kids were so locked down
certain areas it's worse than areas that
were locked down because the kids
weren't around other kids and didn't
build the immune system so they're stuck
inside so now our RSV is flying through
the [ __ ] roof they won't take any
credit they won't take any
accountability like nope it's popping
hops we can overran make sure your
boosters like what
yeah it's not my son it's not that's my
son's had uh he's been coughing coughing
coughing for a long time it's nuts dude
yep there's no any accountability and he
talks about keep wearing those masks we
know for a fact through science it's not
misinformation that only the n95 will
prevent anything and even that doesn't
do the job but those cloth masks and
[ __ ] that he wore for years yeah we know
for a fact there's nothing if he's still
pushing it is he oh yeah so he's also a
thousand years old he's 90. yeah so in
very good shape for his age but you know
it's still very it's for him it's what I
think there was a lot of that too
it's crazy to me yeah you know a lot of
this comes down also to people who are
trustworth trusting and who do what
they're told and it's not a bad thing
and and some people who wore masks for a
year and a half and did all the right
things and social distances didn't see
their own relatives and stuff when the
virus came along when the vaccine came
along
for them they were like of course this
is going to work number one I've trusted
you this has got to work and I could see
my parents I could see my people so
you're emotionally going to put all your
you're going to emotionally back that
thing to the nth degree because and then
when people aren't getting back you keep
me with my parents [ __ ] so you
can see how these are this is was such
an emotional [ __ ] issue oh insane and
sometimes it's just I get it from both
sides yeah yeah it's also just in our
DNA as Americans go hold up why yes yes
it's not normal for us to go oh yes yes
government thank you I'll put the mask
on vaccinated I'm not doing that tell us
why yeah give us proof seems a little
early which is a healthy healthy thing
that's what makes us great yes it's not
a dictatorship we don't like yes I agree
I'll tell you what's a bummer you know
what I'm thinking about it I'm thinking
about Korean short ribs keep going oh
interesting I just wanted to think of
them yeah but they do have a nice uh
Thanksgiving meal there I bet it's
better than one my girl's gonna cook
yeah I don't forget that yeah it looks
delicious over there and they do have
apple pie and pecan my favorite but my
name is
your teeth
no the toothpastes have been working
fantastic
It's Not Gonna Last Forever Bob that's
what the guy said I'm begging you I know
no I'm gonna go it's on the way home
it's literally right up the street it's
on the way home it makes all the sense
it's too easy not to do you know I'm
with you hey do you know what's alarming
is we've had seven mass shootings in
seven days what's left or right and you
see there's just a shooting at Walmart
in Virginia yeah there's some problems
it
do we have any insight into that
particular one it was a manager who
worked at the Walmart what's going on
with us that we have this much mental
illness and this much desperation this
much crazy
well it's also the easiest way to hurt a
lot of people right and now is it a
function on social media where you are
able to get into a bubble of thinking I
don't think it's social media because
we'll assuming everyone but does it
trigger people are already crazy people
are already hanging on by it by the
thread I think they find themselves in
the same Loop maybe I don't know if it's
all I don't think you can blame it on
social media I think a lot of it too is
is uh it's just copycats like those like
when when the strongest thing when the
Columbine shooting happened dude even as
a kid it happened in you know my home
state right up the street from us
you never heard that was the first
you've heard of it how many shootings
have you heard since since then dude yes
yeah I watched a video breakdown of
somebody going like the profile of these
guys like that's the go-to expression of
how whatever they're essentially like
committing suicide even if they kill
themselves or not versus like the way a
woman everything's different and the
profile of these guys
typically leads to the same type of
fantasies and the same type of
expression of this grandiosity and a
grievement and I think the copycat
nature of it
is always understated almost because in
different cultures like I remember
there's this island in the Pacific my
friend wrote the script about it we're
like
two people killed themselves like a
Romeo and Juliet kind of thing or like a
star-crossed lovers and then like
everyone's replicating that like all
these teenagers across the whole island
you've never heard of it but it's like a
cultural phenomenal well I think that
movie that movie on Netflix 13 or
whatever that came out like teen suicide
went by like 20 like what the [ __ ] yeah
they just get these ideas people aren't
original yeah all these Masters they're
just [ __ ] morons they're just copying
they know it's these way to hurt people
that's right
so that that message in Walmart before
like in 91 or whatever say 1990 if you
had a disagreement with your management
at Walmart some you if we can cross your
mind and get a assault rifle yeah never
but yeah it was even everyone's having
it's it's planted everyone's head now
it's nuts damn Walmart manager killed
six people just start spraying and then
he uh it was in the break room [ __ ] and
he killed himself yeah
the first I heard this was Nathan Dunlap
in Aurora Colorado because I lived
behind it in the apartments at Chuck E
cheese
that story is
I've never been to Chuck E cheese since
yeah he's not doing it yeah seven and
seven days why don't they have uh why
don't they have armed guards and [ __ ]
I guess I guess what do you mean
everywhere every Story come on I would
and I'm Walmart every single Walmart you
know my Walmart but there hasn't been
that many shoes I know [ __ ] it the
problem is like the it's the exception
right we say the exception like man I
don't know it's hard to be the norm I
feel like I wanna I want a gun
yeah I want on me when I can just pull
it out by my
it's [ __ ] scary man
you gotta train it's happening so much
yeah
the other scary ones that that uh that
College in Idaho those four kids
oh man butchered with that Rambo style
knife they never found well they say the
cops there have more info
and uh they're not report they're not
releasing it right now because they're
they're they're close it's it's they
don't want the public to know just some
serial killer or what no because because
to kill that intimate and stuff like
that there's gonna be a relationship
except for remember Raleigh uh was it
Raleigh or remember the killings uh when
that guy was he he came into the
dormitory and just cut people's heads
off and mounted them up on the bookshelf
do you remember that no no not Jackson I
think it was Jacksonville right oh he
recently so there was a guy who came in
and killed a bunch of students in a
sorority and then men and women let's
Ted Bundy same thing but he cut their
heads off put them on the bookshelf then
took arms and just did all this weird
[ __ ] and then he found out it was a
serial killer who just wanted to do
something evil and they found him there
no no no no no The Co-Ed Killer no
uh just go to Raleigh or Raleigh or um
Jacksonville it was a
yeah no that's not
hold on let's see
Joseph Phillips I'll tell you in a
second Danny rowings yeah maybe game
five yeah Gainesville Gainesville
Gainesville Ripper yeah he murdered five
students that's right
oh dang it you just go back there's
another article he just wanted to do
something terrible
and he inspired scream so this is a hot
second of me well the course of four
days ago killer Danny Rollins terrorized
the college students of Gainesville
Florida
uh Denny Rowling lived on a happy life
could sing too really oh yeah great
singer hold on over the course of four
days in 1990 okay throw back okay I like
where you're gonna adjust it right right
just right here's me Danny
um actually caught for the murders it
was only when he was arrested for an
unrelated burglary charged that he
confess to some of the most horrific
murders in Florida's history and with
unmasked as the Gainesville Ripper
inspired the the movie it's great this
is right yeah
uh but he mounted their heads though
that's the oh yeah all this kind of keep
going down forget his childhood I'm sure
it was terrible who gives a [ __ ]
foreign
let's finish it off though he broke into
residence after he raped her removed her
nipples and placed them sizes rolling
cut off her head and sat her upright on
the edge of her bed
the Gainesville River put her head on
the book that's what it was Brian put it
on a bookshelf yeah dude by now
newspapers spare across yeah now think
about it her father found her that way
that's great that's
um
yeah
by the way I gotta pee so bad is can we
take this all right
uh but you got to see him sing a song in
in jail okay he's better Manson oh yeah
sang the song to the girl he's the girl
married him in jail and he goes I just
want to sing a song to uh my lady if you
don't mind and like you're like holy
[ __ ] pinky finger to the Moon put your
pinky finger to the Moon that's what I
mean that's Bruno Mars dude he can sing
in Spanish and in English God he's so
small in person he's the best performer
ever yeah he's a tiny guy small guy
loves him some kokahina
if I wish he was uh I want him I want to
look like that but it's six foot two and
be able to sing like you saw him next to
Taylor Swift right his pictures
though yeah but still the picture with
him like pumpkin jack yeah but
um I want uh but also Bruno uh my buddy
oh my boy Matt did uh he shot it that's
not even like photoshopped God that's
hilarious
there's a lot of Talent on that stage
yeah I'll drink a water he's a little
dude wait what some of these are fun but
this is getty that's real that's real
wait yeah is that is that that's Taylor
Swift with heels on too so she's about
seven two he is a tiny little guy very
gay she's seven two no he's not he's not
gay oh my Daddy really some cocaine and
some tits is his thing is that true yeah
my butt yo dude he's gone on record
saying he likes women yeah yeah he has a
kid no he uh my buddy uh Matt shot his
uh music video he said I've never seen
anything like it he controls everything
oh I bet he said can I shoot he's like
yeah but you're not posting or
Distributing anything until I check off
on it he's like oh damn yeah he's um
Savage yeah amazingly talented couch and
I think a video that I saw earlier so
the shooter's dad in Colorado Springs
the dad fought in the UFC once he fought
Andre Lasky lost
um
I was shocked at this interview really
because his daddy you know he's like
yeah I thought it was a shooting and you
know and then I found my son I was like
what the hell he said I thought a gay
club I'm thinking myself am I son gay
and then he's not gay thank God man I'm
a republican conservative and you're
like
well no it's not about your son being
gay or not so he murdered people you
[ __ ] and how terrible is your CT does
he know his son are they close I don't
know my guess is they're not
is that they are not that's him multiple
people this is me in 20 years
[Music]
well you guys have had conversations
about that you you were wrong
those scars on his face yeah he's a mess
um
I don't know well he's accused of going
on a mass shooting at a gay bar and
killing fight he called him okay well
I got [ __ ] that was cute
Jesus
that kid that kid didn't have a shot no
they also did there's no relationship
there no he had no relationship that
guy's not that guy's not a relationship
with himself he gets a piece of [ __ ]
there's nothing going on with it and
also a Conservative Republican uh tell
us the policies on that he's not all
he's not all fans can you just give us
one policy that uh Republicans trying to
you know I don't know I mean you know
also the guy clearly did math and it's
he's more worried about some being gay
than murder I know what the [ __ ] how
stupid is that your dad yeah well he's
not all there that's not a guy dealing
with a full deck right no he's not that
guy and by the way
uh unless you beat the show yeah and he
might also just be in general what
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] but also you
know I know you're gay if you're that
upset about yourself that's what's going
on yeah
I said you're not more upset that you
said murder people yeah yeah you know I
know you think dicks are delicious you
beat up gay people
that that was always that was a lot of
the case you'd see guys who would quote
unquote gay bash I'm old enough to
remember this [ __ ] people would you
probably got gay bad I I almost did
actually because I was wearing a certain
pair of shoes I bet uh physique yep and
uh and uh but those men that do that
are either just very bad sadistic people
or they're they just they have something
that's so much anger yeah now formal
Angel issues about it yeah all right you
can get some current events all right uh
first one great news this is for we know
cave good news released on one million
dollar bill wow this is great right so
he's with his family for the holidays
which is awesome hell yeah and then uh
so he's also granted permission to do a
pro wrestling event the Lucha Libre type
of person Arizona it's really really
talented at it yeah and here's the thing
this judge is badass this judge is dope
then listen the judge has some of the
evidence wait till this trial starts
from what I hear from certain Birds
close situation
it's gonna go Kane's way wait till you
hear more details
right but he's still
put the public in Jeopardy don't get me
wrong he's gonna he's gonna serve some
penalties but not what you're thinking
can I get can I get a body like Paul
Acosta can I have that body please no
Jesus Christ absolutely not does he have
the best body of all time in the UFC
would you say he's up there I mean one
of the best who's got a better young
vetor for sure back in the day
of course James Irvin back in the day
too had a yellow Houston Alexander yeah
look at a young uh Young Veterans
Sterling I think has one of the best
movies
nobody's too small
was there a weight limit that I wasn't
wearing no I'm talking about six two no
we're talking about big boys that's a
big boy no by far the best body of all
time there's no discussion look Rocco no
no no he's an Uber ring at heavier yeah
could have placed second in Olympia yeah
but his castle yeah that's that's though
that's
that's to me too big and too that was
interesting too Juiced up
I said it and the other proportions yes
like he has the genetic gifts and the
other guys Brian Baba
palacosta well I'm gonna say this you
want me to go through my my best bodies
in the UFC without number one number one
let's beat your bell for it no
number one
in a lot of ways it's Gotta Be You All
Romero yeah he's great too you feel like
a ninja turtle I mean Luke at six three
natural huh over right over right you
said it natural
okay keep going though because you took
out ubering because you say he's not
natural but keep going
keep going
I mean you are Romero is so [ __ ] just
under Mark's defense
but to March defense algeman Sterling
this last Wayne pound for pound
top three of all time his body his last
name he's just a little bit a little
small but we're just saying like
shredded well no like when he weighed in
though do the weigh-in 100 he looks
fantastic ridiculous body fantastic but
did nice pods up too no it's still not
you know no it's still I'm talking you
got to be I'm talking about the 85s
205ers yeah we like some meat we like I
like beer I need height I need meat and
height I mean now now who are you saying
Jared canonier no I mean um uh Kennedy
about his great Hollander is a camera
Canada
yeah God damn he's built
um
where where is the other guy um who are
you saying so we got we have rockhold
obviously shuin Vitor Belfort I agree
with you young Victor young Vitor was
just stupid canonier's got a great
[ __ ] physique when he's yeah not not
so much on the left though right no but
so
strong looking good yeah
it keeps going to small black guys yeah
I need legs no he's 170. he's 170 in the
day weighs in yes but I mean we're
talking about but I need eggs I need
legs and ass bubbles you said a small
black I don't think but but I go I go
legs I go legs small person legs Nest
first then you got chest shoulders arms
no usman's not six foot tall your Swiss
man is he's about that oh man I think
he's surprised
Wikipedia yeah I found on the show
several times have you yeah yeah I mean
I've stood next to him and I I think
he's I'll be surprised
you're taller so it's hard for you
you know I don't I don't know if he's
six foot man maybe
yeah
what's that
okay Omar you think the height and
weights of the internet's real no so do
you think you think Francis is 6'4
that's how you think he is press tall
and I am hmm
they had Shane Carol is that six three
270 pounds
Shane is not six three it's about six
three right no no sure
one of the best friends for many years
right right so at the NFL combine he was
listed at six foot now maybe in his
older age he grew
but I that's that's Up For Debate I
don't know I remember Shane being taller
than me but that's why you always
weighed in with Air Maxes on oh you'd
always weigh in with Air Max and then
all the pic no those pictures the Air
Maxes on he would never take a picture
without his shoes on oh because he was
okay because he's shorter oh you know
you know what you know what Bubba you
did train with him I'm not going to say
anything
you were a lot taller than he was there
you go
but by the way every bit of 285 when I
met him oh my God massive look at that
picture there look massive yeah yeah
yeah yeah massive and that's Aaron
Hernandez with Roy Nelson so that's cool
but um but but I gotta go with uh we're
going back to best bodies
young people Gotta Give It Up to him
yeah I feel like we're missing somebody
though I know we are we're leaving out
one big one
podcast is definitely up there yeah
holocaster was just no no no no give me
Vitor
GSP was him I mean the trtv tour was big
but as you know when he was young huge
traps down there to the left right there
to the left
yeah did I see that picture where he's
going like this he's older there what
about a young Ken Shamrock oh ken was
maybe so and he's like a pro wrestler
kind of type of body that's a great body
right there vitoris is a good looking
guy the face went with it and all that I
mean he looked good you know really good
there my memory of veto when he's
younger was way bigger but looking back
at these pictures he wasn't like
naturally I feel like a guy I feel like
we're from somebody
we're forgetting a big boy hold on hold
on let me think Mark Coleman bring up
the ratings no I know who I know the
greatest body I'd ever seen was the
wrestler uh who got addicted to
painkills Mark oh no uh marker marker
I saw him gay man as well yes and I saw
him when I was in um Joe Rogan and I
were one of the first ufcs and he came
out you know he knocked out Mike stock
and he came out in a pair of American
flags hell yeah and I was like oh my
Lord Francis by the way Francis I'm
gonna write too bad himself but he's
just so big that you almost are like
yeah well
okay
what are all these this is the best
bodies five best physiques and Michael
Stanley has really You Gotta Give it up
but again like yeah
I want height I want height
I mean how can somebody might be number
one I I active but yeah I mean look at
that that is when you find the
parameters what are the weight classes
and what are the 85 and up okay just the
kind of body you want in general
number one on there osman's got a great
body but for me and Brian we like we
like some meat we like meat we like
Bears we came to a bodybuilding contest
because he's too low like he doesn't
have the bodybuilding proportions
Overeem does have this like he has a
Arnold like yes it depends on what you
like I I like number one best of all
times over it most jacked over him Kyle
Kingsburg how's King bear he was good
Kyle Kingsbury Sean shirk smaller but 55
but he was Jack just terrible teeth
terrible teeth yeah two teeth
if he bit you were [ __ ] yeah
Kyle Kingsbury has a question he's oh
check on his body's good small legs
small legs that's my problem thank you I
was about to say the yard he was there
for a little while Kyle's kingbury yeah
jacked yeah I think he goes down the uh
psychedelic route oh big time yeah I
think he's done I think he's gone to the
Sun and back
um
pop here Betty I don't know these guys
just be a good body too yeah he did
oh it's okay
too short yeah too short you always up
there yeah
Paul Castro on everybody's list
with all the testing I believe that most
of them yeah
because obviously like most people point
to him as somebody who looks like
they're on steroids but he won that
lawsuit remember that yeah oh that's he
got popped that's right and then he took
it to court and because of the
circumstances like it was in New Jersey
and there was some like it tripled his
settlement so I don't know how much he
saw of it but it was some insane amount
yeah but I I looked at it apparently
that yeah it's like 30 million dollars
34 million dollars but that company went
bankrupt so I guess they don't pay it
how long did he uh fight for him for a
while because he's done The Ultimate
Fighter too and I cornered against Kyle
Kingsbury when I record Pat Cummins
hell of a wrestler his last fight was
Pat Cummins that was in 2014 holy [ __ ]
started 2009 years ago 2000 almost nine
years ago
monster oh an ultimate fighter he fought
from 45 for six years far for a minute
Jesus
yeah
boy had a tough run those last four yeah
great guy though yeah what else you got
Jay
um let's see
he's all that uh artem Sun Conor
McGregor wow yeah we're so close
apparently not so apparently so artem uh
he has a master's degree which I didn't
know right from Dublin City University
in finance yeah so he's like a legit
dude he had the big brain on Brad and
apparently he's the one that according
to artem he's the one that kind of got
the deal done together you know hit up
all these different companies
any contractor no no no no let me can I
give you a quick bullet points to talk
about this on my podcast just now so
when Conor McGregor was going to work
with hathor bjornson on a vodka artem
claims that he said no no you want to do
a whisper Irish Irish whiskey and in
college I made this like presentation
about how Irish whiskey dominates the
market let me show you so he persuaded
him to do whiskey so you should do your
own brand and then I'm gonna contact all
these distilleries uh you know in order
to like figure out who you should work
with so it gave him all this
and then Connor and exchange I guess
said like hey man I want to give you a
million bucks and artem turned it down
so that's the key thing is did he turn
it down and say just give me five
percent says
entitled to five percent based on an
agreement I guess a herbal agreement
right but you would hinge on that if you
just turned it down because oh yeah he'd
always offer me like money for the fight
campsite and I'd never take it was like
well if you're if he's saying a million
bucks turned out don't invent something
later but if Conor agreed to five
percent so I'm assuming they're not
friends anymore right because he sucks
you'd have to because I mean I had that
close to it I mean I know what you're
gonna give me on this and I know that my
daddy well I work for my 20 yeah
all right Thirty I don't care yeah she
said I was the one who said when I said
you should do a [ __ ] whiskey I came
up with a name right that's gonna be
tough in a court of law to be like no
he's sad yeah it's gonna be tough
let's just settled out of court
and it's also sad because like
they seemed really I know to be genuine
Thailand so I imagine it had to go
through a lot to get to this point I
know that's a bummer
and this is just Conor's face which I
think is so interesting these days
yeah
yeah
um that's a um so it's such a different
thing it's a meaty meaty face and he's
gigantic now
yeah
I mean look at him he's out of the
testing protocol I mean it's clearly
what he's doing do you I'm with UFC
that's your cash cow but yeah you gotta
testing protocol do what you need to do
get your leg fixed and get back
oh yeah we'll be back but the problem is
is it's gonna be a hot second because
you can't fight unless you're back in
the protocol for six months of clean
testing yeah so he's still not even in
the testing protocol unless they're
gonna figure out a way to cheat their
way through that I don't know what they
do
well
he um he looks so much better with a
beard yeah he's got a
he's a [ __ ] that's that's those are
some shoulders kids okay so he's been
shouldered up yeah now um
he deleted the other picture though man
we had that movement George he's such a
fighter look at him he looks like
grabass in the Park yeah he looks like a
Celtic Warrior and yeah take it easy huh
what else you got Jen now now he's
coming back to the 55 pound division
yeah correct that's it
okay
um all right so this is apparently this
is a footage from Conor McGregor oh no
sorry Kanye West
talking to uh Adidas heads
I'll show you this right here
look at this video here apparently these
are Adidas execs that Kanye showed them
pictures of I guess Kim Kardashian naked
and then also them having sex or
something like that sounds like a gift
okay so oh yeah
and you mentioned this before how like
uh they took ideas they took like this
this the look of the shoes and
everything else and they sold it yeah
without his consent they're like no we
signed you a six year deal he's like
hold up that's not part of the deal
what room are they in
and it's weird how it's like filmed in
like a Vanette and this guy's on Kanye's
side
[Music]
there are easy things
[Music]
see the media is trying to make him seem
crazy oh he's showing them porno no he's
doing as an example to show yeah so as
it says here like you guys are
uncomfortable right that wasn't cool
right that's how I made the channel
yeah the extreme example he's so it's
very very extreme but the media came out
was like Kanye was showing employees
porn of course now he's now there and
now he put this out [ __ ] oh ridiculous
to you with um yeah man I I
think that they they clearly stole his
[ __ ] ideas that's [ __ ] up
man I was making profit off it selling
it under Adidas not easy shady [ __ ]
that's what I wanted a gap too I think
yep they start making his clothes
without his name yeah like no it's part
of the deal this is older but this was a
cool story so Lamar Odom I guess a big
fan of his who was obviously pretty rich
he bought the the rings that Lamar Odom
sold when he was going through some
tough times that's cool he bought them
for thirty six thousand and seventy
thousand and they just gave them to him
that's for free yeah he's a fan Super
Fan that's really cool that's really
classic dude
really he was that good oh he was almost
what six eleven handles you know what's
do you know what's funny is watching him
box was held like he was so terrible oh
yeah and it's like it's great an athlete
as it was boxing was not for him
so I missed this on chop show apparently
the pfl the the pay-per-view the first
one they're ever doing is this weekend I
had no idea so
let's look at the car how much is the
paper feel 49.99 I think which is kind
of crazy yeah and this is a Kayla
Harrison fighting someone that she beat
already twice
and what else what else is let's see
Beast they can't find anybody the card
is kind of crazy there's some um UFC
like uh veterans from UFC like Stevie
Ray all of you I'm glad Julia buds
yeah
debut because she walks around like what
175 well this one was at 155 yeah big
big lady one of the Marias is on the pre
prelims Gleason t-ball is in there
interesting oh my God yeah let's give me
a tough sell for 55 I know dude I wonder
why they're doing that and it was like I
didn't see any promotion at all I didn't
even know yeah we do a [ __ ] fight I
know
um all right let's go to Mark stuff one
and who would pay for a paper
I know it's just I don't know what
they're doing if it was like cyborg or
somebody somebody you know an outlier
you could do that as a pay-per-view but
that card I'd like to watch Cyborg and
her go at it so if you guys saw this but
Antonio Brown apparently posted a nude
picture of Giselle through his Snapchat
but did you see look at that stuff from
the text Tom was like man I've been
nothing but supportive of giving me so
much love try to get you away from those
people who are just leeches around you
and he's like and you're doing exactly
what they all told you you're gonna do
you're self-sabotaging yourself he's
like I won't be part of it anymore send
this long text but why would he even do
this like what is this for crazy just to
[ __ ] with Tom because you're going
through a divorce it's not cool it's
super not cool
um but that's not even her look at her
face that's not that funny insane
photoshopped I mean also he's a dick
yeah that's a total dick yeah Tommy
reach out to him he posted the things
like look what Tom said he's like man
sounds like you really helped you out
let you stay with him and vouch for you
yeah that guy he's got mental illness
[ __ ] that guy he's a bad guy all right
douchebag Marcus
all right so I hear plummets a thousand
feuds were deaf after slipping on the
ledge so to show the slip yeah let's see
if we can find it I don't want to see
her die well I'd like to see her fall
because I don't want to see that my
question is why do people put themselves
in these positions no let's not see it
that's sad disaster
and uh bring it up right now
so that's her there
disaster occurred around 4 P.M on Sunday
wall masako who lived in feltre was
hiking with three friends in the
dolomites the highest peak in which
measures nearly 11 000 feet tall they
reportedly walking single file along the
ledge to a pass when the Alpine has
slipped and fell screaming into Ravine
outside dog that's awful that poor girl
[ __ ] she's beautiful too that's a bummer
man
yeah but it is you know it is you are
taking on that risk and I think people
submit forget that it's like not like
skydiving in September 79 year old man
filled his death while hiking with two
daughters same area huh Australia yeah
this is kind of what happens when you uh
it's it's it's a risk yeah but that [ __ ]
is I'm reading a book right now actually
it's a fall like you know it's a big
fall so you gotta think about it I'm
reading a book right now by a guy who
climbed all set you know it's called
America's Grand Slam and he's like the
first American to climb like all the
ties all the Peaks and when they were
going to climb K2 and they were like you
know it just looks kind of bad and 14
people went up and died all 14 of them
or something it's like that's the kind
of stakes you play there's some there's
some girl in the [ __ ] I think she
doesn't have a leg just do it she has
one one left read that book
if you're in a guy with two legs
this lady has one okay dude I don't know
dude you salty [ __ ] okay man I'm sorry
I apologize a dark episode fine kid dark
fire kid dark I'm having a [ __ ] I'm
having a text thing with Sasso who's
telling me that I should uh that he goes
uh I'm putting a lot of money on me
anyway and I go on what he goes our
fight I go or fight I don't want he goes
no we're gonna have a boxing match I'll
guess after a round but I'll catch you
I'm probably gonna whale on your head
but that's good for Ratings better we're
gonna graphical I don't want to do this
he goes now you're doing it
we've got to get it back yes he was busy
he couldn't he couldn't make it what's
this
um all right so I guess Julia Fox uh who
used to date Kanye West
has uh a little NSFW description of his
dong [ __ ] dude you can never get away
with anything I know what the [ __ ] dude
is she so famous from uncut gems and
then she started with Kanye the actress
was more than happy to be throw in her
description of her ex's penis when asked
about it on z-way Sunday tell me when to
stop Hostess away told the uncut gem
star while moving her hands while I
don't know when the comedian 30 comedian
had her hands almost as wide as her
shoulders Fox 32 told her to make it
smaller until it appeared to be about a
foot long oh my God
uh z-way shattered she's saying that's
how big oh that's all sizes was super
imposed that's all good you know that's
cool as long as she's not talking [ __ ]
then that's cool yeah she's saying he's
got it so she went on the show
I wasn't expecting you to answer that
the funny part or like the weird part is
hate comes in all sizes was superimposed
over the thing yeah of course like
that's the only thing come on go back no
she is definitely hot Julia Fox hold on
no several months ago no yeah no Brian's
just fine now better you know I know
she's in that movie I'm waiting for the
movie I'm waiting for the book to come
out is she in it or is she just she's in
it yeah she's his girlfriend she's a
good movie so stressful yeah he's like
such a it's such a good movie
um and then
she while Fox appeared happy to be
dating the flashing lights rapper
earlier this year she has since changed
her tune and now claims she only dated
him to help his ex-wife Kim Kardashian
she was cool I saw that [ __ ] thing
and it was just cool I had this thought
and I was like oh my God maybe I can get
him off Kim's case yeah because he needs
that help that's lame though come on I
mean and also it's over so you're still
talking yes
let me get back to acting Yeah well yeah
whatever
okay
um she's cool though
uh yes so there was this lady who uh she
Sparks outrage by climbing this pyramid
you know I guess you're not supposed to
do this right I would try to do it you
know you're not allowed to climb the
Mayan pyramids yeah I guess I guess I
didn't realize this before a renegade
tourist who was met by a furious mob
after climbing an ancient Mayan pyramid
of Mexico's this week has been
identified as a 29 year old Mexican
national I can't touch her she's Mexican
um
she attempted she had attempted to pass
herself off as a Spaniard after she was
arrested for her viral stunt but has
since been determined she's actually
from Mexico the security guard's like
God damn she thought she was being
celebrated
oh they're saying killer yeah they want
her to be sacrificed they want to
sacrifice like the minds if it's a
sacred land yeah then why you wanna
climb all the way up up there go in and
it was right and it wasn't just the
climbing gasket she was also doing Tick
Tock dances oh wow so she didn't know
she doesn't know oh you don't think so
no I think that's why she's trying to
pass
from Mexico I would have thought so too
I wouldn't know oh I wouldn't know
because I'm not a [ __ ]
also hey hey guys it's fine that you
climb the Merit pyramid it's fine
they're trying to beat her now it's like
a it's like don't touch the statue
because if everybody was doing it okay
yeah you know but
they're I think yeah they're acting what
was that mayor Adams right there what
was that is that another current event
no no uh those are uh ads right B
right there yeah a little stupid huh
those are other ads right what do you
mean it's just like no no they're
looking at the the Mayan one right so
this is another article so all those on
the side no I was saying the one that
was just there but come here Adams New
York Post this video here yeah yeah it's
just like so it just does like extra you
know it's my additional videos
you're stupid you're stupid I feel like
she didn't know and she wanted to climb
yeah people want to like no idea what
they're doing
tick tocks and Instagram it's
Thanksgiving man yes it is we have to be
thankful we have a gobble [ __ ] I don't
have anything to give you I'll get some
grade before you dead no I don't want
any of your gravity Naples Florida off
the hook Comedy Club December one two
three and four let's go Boston
Massachusetts awesome huh that's a lot
of nice a lot of nice Bobby Bubba it's
going to be tough uh live Boston
December 29 30 31 and then we got San
Diego California Mike drop Comedy Club
January 5 6 and 7. I hear good things
about that club four-way in Indiana
Summit Comedy Club January 12th to the
14th Daddy doesn't take time off oh my
God Danny of Florida January is a busy
[ __ ] I'm just realizing that January
but I'm taking Feb off
we got a fight companion maybe and we
got a I'm going to I'm going to uh yeah
all right yeah what do you got buddy uh
December the last tour date of the Year
2022 December 1st through the 3rd
Providence Rhode Island those shows are
damn they're sold out get your tickets
now at fatkz.com thick boy merch drops
you're watching the promo right now
thick boy merch drops at 6 a.m Pacific
Time on thickboy.com the official MLB
thick boy jerseys same quality as the
the players wear on the field we have
two different jerseys the military
inspired one then also the brown and
yellow we got the hats we got jerseys
I'm sure sorry hoodies to match and then
the rest of the site just till Cyber
Monday is 35 off the new items are not
on sale but everything else is 35 off
get yourself at thickboy.com and then
we're doing five dollars off shipping on
the tiger thick award winning whiskey go
to type uh go to thinkboy.com and click
on tiger thick to order that bottle
straight to your doorstep again time for
Christmas but the first the third I'm in
Providence Rhode Island get you
something I have big announcement coming
up for January tour might be heading up
north to see my Canadians big tour
coming announced all right oh by the way
real quick um for a Toe Hold uh for uh
Black Friday is that what is we're
running a great sale one one dollar off
oh wow yeah it's one dollar off so guys
get your [ __ ] uh get your [ __ ]
awesome flip-flops handbags uh your hats
uh rash guards we got it all for you and
wallets uh so there you go one dollar
off wow yeah all right kids Province
you're up see you guys soon we're out